voici
Ricky salut toi salut et là bonjour Cet
été replongé dans l'aventure attention
vous serez tortu de rire on les a eu
grandpère
attend Sam
[Musique]
grand-père qu'est-ce que de boutchou
comme vous font ici tout seul on est à
la recherche de nos grand-pères ils les
ont mené à la
bienvenue dans le plus grand aquarium du
monde des humains sous l'eau c'est quoi
cet endroit il faut qu'on s'vade et tout
de suite la situation sur le terrain est
un désastre absolu vous pouvez nous
aider à les retrouver s'il vous plaît
tout le monde saccroche en
route cible verrouillé oh j'ai été
touché
génial attention ah
poisson rejoignez nos deux héros quel un
brudti pour une grande traversée là
Ricky votre malheureux petit plan
d'évasion est ruiné c'est ce que tu
crois je sais comment les faire sortir
de
la
[Musique]
action accrochez-vous à vos carapaces
c'est parti on y
va Sami 2
ça a l'air super marrant l'aventure
continue en
3D le 15 août au
cinéma